(gentle music)
♪ Yeah okay it's Tea ♪
♪ With GaryVee ♪
♪ Sipping info tea ♪
♪ I know patience is the key ♪
♪ Putting up all of my shit for free ♪
♪ This is Tea ♪
♪ With GaryVee ♪
♪ Might go make a flip ♪
♪ Take a risk ♪
- Good morning, tea fans.
It is me Gary Vee.
Early morning, 9am Eastern Time
on this May 15th, halfway
through this month.
We're just kind of all going through this
so I hope everybody is super well.
I've missed you guys,
leave a comment if you missed
"Tea With GaryVee" yesterday.
Let me know.
'Cause it's nice to be missed
'cause I missed you guys heavy.
Good morning.
Hello.
Let's give some shout
out to Tatiana Spencer.
Good to see you here.
Casey Smith.
Thank you, Julio Garcia.
Great to see you, Max
Hendricks, good morning.
Big shout out to everybody
who just came over
from text on Community.
If you're not following me on text,
212-931-5731,
text me, lock me in when
the contact card comes out,
fill out the info get with me on it.
A lot of fun there.
If you just came over from text
'cause I just blasted all of you,
said, "Come and join me for some tea."
Leave a comment saying, "Text"
just reply text, whatever
platform you're using,
YouTube, Facebook, Twitter, Twitch.
It's good to have all of you here so.
Yeah, there we go, I see
some people, love it.
Yes, __ me.
We'll get to that right hook
at some point here today.
All right, let's get into it.
Dustin, how are you?
Dust, before we get into it.
- Good.
- Your hair's looking good.
- (laughs) Yeah, took a shower last night
and went straight to bed.
And this is what happens.
- I appreciate that. (laughs)
I just ran up a huge hill, eight times,
cardio for life.
- Jesus, oh no.
I can't do that in the morning.
- Yeah, I'm not sure how I did it either.
- Wait, this is the camera
setup that me and Dewark
were telling you about.
So I don't know if you can tell
any difference on your end.
- Yeah, it looks good.
- Cool, so yeah I'll--
- What do you mean?
My camera is better?
- No, this camera.
My camera.
- My camera looks better too.
'cause there's good lighting today.
- Yeah, probably that's why.
- Your camera?
This is the camera
you're gonna send to me?
- Yeah.
- I can't really tell a difference--
- Okay, well, maybe--
- Hopefully mine is better,
but it's lighting too.
It's all that shit, all right.
Let's get into it.
- Gary.
(Gary claps)
What's up, man?
- Abel, It is so good to see you, bro.
- Good to see you too, man.
Wow, it's been forever.
- It's been a long time.
I've moved in seventh grade
and then I saw you at the
Hillsborough fire station,
baseball card comic show,
sophomore year or junior
year of high school,
since '92 or '93.
And that's it.
- That's when I came back.
- Oh yeah, 'cause that triggered,
you also moved, right?
- Yeah, I moved to Florida with my family.
- At the end of seventh grade too?
- Yeah, right at the end of
seventh grade going into eight.
- So we both bounced
John Adams Middle School?
- Got out of John Adams,
right at the same time.
- And then you came back
and graduated JP Stevens?
- No, no, I just came back to see family
and then went to see you.
So yeah, that was cool, man.
You sold me my first
baseball card, Gary Carter,
way back in the day.
- You know what's funny.
Every time I stumble on
anybody that I grew up with,
the first thing they say is,
"You sold me my first"--
- Baseball card?
Yeah, that was true, man.
It's true.
- I hustled those hard back then.
- Yeah, you did, man.
You did, you hustled everything hard.
Everything hard, man.
People who read about
you, that stuff's true.
I remember when you were
a kid taking flowers
and selling them to the people.
Now, let me ask you a question.
Did you sell 'em
to the same people those
garden you took it out of?
Or was it neighbors?
- Neighbors, but
sometimes the same garden.
- Still man, that sounds crazy.
That's crazy, yeah.
- It's so good to see you, bro.
- Good to see you too, man.
Good to see you too.
- I honestly, I don't even really
have a question.
- Yeah I just wanted to see you too.
(Abel laughs)
My favorite part of this,
of us connecting is,
WrestleMania six or five, five.
We watched WrestleMania when
Macho Man lost to Hogan.
That was at your house and I--
- You were devastated.
- Devastated.
- That was right around the time
that I knew that it was scripted.
So I knew what was gonna play out.
But I was still devastated.
- Oh, I know, yeah,
that was back when
wrestling was good, man.
You know, it was awesome.
And I remember that was the
first time my mom met you
when you came over to my house.
And for like two minutes,
she talked to you.
She went out to find me.
And she's like, "Why can't
you be more your friend Gary?
And I'm, "You don't even know the guy.
"He could be a horrible guy."
And she's like, "Well, is he?"
and I'm like, "That's not the damn point."
You know what I mean?
But it was funny, man, was good times.
I think some of the best friends you have
are the ones when you're kids
because it's before all the
bullshit, you know what I mean?
- You know it's crazy, when I think back,
we really, really got close at John Adams,
That's when our friendship
got much stronger
in sixth and seventh grade.
Were you there when I fought
Oded Weinstock at Marcos Hill?
- Oded Weinstock, yes, I was.
You whoop his ass.
- That was a big one.
That was a big one for me.
That's my highlight of middle School.
- Oh, that was funny.
Hey man, do you remember Rajan Courtney?
Remember them?
- Rajan was my guy.
In fourth grade, he was the only other kid
that was great at dodge ball.
Rajan was my guy, guy.
- Oh, yeah, that was awesome.
But I remember me and Rajan,
we were kind of close but not really
but before we were close,
it was after school one day
and he wanted to fight me.
Yeah, and you know, you
and him and Danny Vega
those were the toughest kids in school.
I remember it was after
school and you know,
the big circle forms and I'm looking,
honestly, I'm looking for you.
I'm like, "Help!"
But I'm not gonna back down--
- Of course not.
This was Jersey in the '80s.
Nobody fucking backed down,
there was fights.
Remember the Williams twins
who were younger but tougher
than fucking everyone?
- Oh my God, yeah, those
were the big kids, right?
- Yes, Roby and,
I'm trying to remember
the other kid's name.
- I don't remember the other one either.
Now, but this is funny
because I remember, the big circle formed.
And then here you come out of nowhere.
You know, I'm ready to fight.
I'm ready to get my ass whooped
'cause I'm gonna fight.
But I don't wanna fight you know.
So here you come
- Your shell was tough.
- Yeah, and I remember you
said, "What's going on here?"
And Rajan is like, "I'm
gonna whoop his ass."
And you said, "Why?"
And he said, "'Cause I don't like him."
And literally, I remember this happening.
You look right at him,
and you went, "Why?"
And he looked at you like
a cow would a new fence.
Yeah and he was like, "Well, all right."
So he didn't whoop my ass
so I never got to thank you for that.
But thanks, man, that was awesome.
Do you remember playing our
version of soccer and hockey
on the sidewalk with the--
- With the fucking rock?
- With the rock too
but with the containers--
- Of a smashed coke.
You ready for this?
This is a true story.
I was so addicted to
that soccer, hockey game
with the rock and the can after school
that I would get home so late
'cause I used to walk home
that my mom would get nervous
'cause I would get home so late.
So finally, it's a true story.
One time my mom goes,
"You have to be home after school today.
"Do not fuck around, no fucking hockey."
My mom, she's shaking her
head in the background.
I go, "Okay, Mom, I promise."
Sure enough, fucking after school,
I'm trying to leave but
the game is so good.
I have to jump in.
Everything's gonna be just one minute
but 30 minutes later, game ends.
Now I'm petrified.
'Cause my mom is fucking
old-school Russian.
She's gonna whip my ass.
This is not some American.
So I start running.
And when I tell you running,
running home full speed.
So it's on a street
and there's a shortcut.
Do you remember Eric Godfrey?
He was a year older than us.
Do you know that name?
You might not know him, but
he was in my neighborhood.
So you could run home and go to the street
but there was a shortcut
that would get me faster.
So I'm running home
and I'm watching every car
that's driving to John Adams,
hoping my mom's car is not there,
'cause I knew she would come.
Sure enough, just as I'm
running down the hill
and I look back to see the final cars
that I could see before I
can't see any more cars.
I see my mom's Mercury
Topaz, fucking driving.
And my fucking, it was over,
I knew it was over.
- Your life flashed
before your eyes.
- I will never forget that.
We loved that game.
So it was soccer/hockey on pavement
with a rock or a crushed soda can.
- Yeah, yeah, it was crazy.
- Abel, I remember that super well.
- I know, that was awesome, man.
That was awesome.
I got a new baby.
- Congratulations.
- Thank you, man.
- Good for you brother.
- 43 years old.
She's gonna have to wheel
me to her graduation but--
- Nah, man, you'll be
the best 61 year-old ever.
- Thank you, I appreciate.
- Abel, so good to see
you brother, I love you.
It's been so good
to reconnect.
- You too, man.
- Talk to you soon.
- All right, take care.
- Good stuff.
It's fun to have those.
You know what's fun is some
of those stories are fun
'cause you forget some of the stuff.
So that was Sean Courtney
story I completely remember now
that it was like, that's 1984 shit.
I always believed in
kindness even back then.
Anyway, let's keep it going.
Hi, Sarah.
- Hey, Gary.
- How are things?
- Things are really
good on the west coast.
- It's early.
Thanks for getting up early.
- Yeah, whatever it takes, of course.
So four years in the
making since I tweeted you,
and you tweeted back.
- So for everybody who's
watching right now,
yesterday, I think you tweeted right?
- Yeah, I just responded to the tweet,
which was like four years ago,
Sarah said something I said,
"Well, we should talk then."
And yesterday, she retweeted
it and wrote over it,
it's like, "Can we book this?"
And I saw it, I'm like,
"Yep, let's book it."
And here we are.
- What's so funny, Gary
is then your team messaged me and says,
"Just get ready with a question."
And I thought this is
what's so funny is that,
I have obviously known about
that tweet for four years
and every time I thought about
messaging you in the past.
It was because I wanted something.
And then I would do this
thing where I'm like,
"What's he gonna tell me?"
He's gonna tell me, "Start
the YouTube channel."
He's gonna tell me (mumbles)
So just do the thing.
And then yesterday,
we were supposed to have
our 10 year celebration
at the organization I'm with.
And I was sitting in my house
not feeling sorry for myself,
but just thinking,
"Damn, I was supposed
to be at that party."
And I'm here
and look what we've done during
the pandemic for our kids.
And I was like, "We haven't
been a victim during this time.
"We've been so resourceful.
"We've been just doing such a great job
"and just on it."
And I thought, "I just
gotta tell him, thank you."
So that's why I did it.
So then when they messaged me, they're
"Do you have a question?"
I mean, I have thought of them obviously,
I've had time to think of it.
But I was like,
"Wait, that's not even
why I did it this time."
- You know what's so powerful about that,
the other times you've thought about it,
it was from a place of need.
- Yes.
- Yesterday was from a place of giving
and the universe decided
to serendipitously allow me to see it.
And then it creates the moment
and I really mean this,
that shit fucking freaks me out.
When I hear that story,
it really makes me believe
there's just something so obvious.
No different, I'm sure you're
just watching with Abel.
Abel still feels the impact
of a third grade fight
that I stopped out of kindness.
Good brings on more good
and bad brings on more bad
and I believe in that shit
and I feel a huge sense of responsibility
as a good communicator
that people are associated with
and attracted to and drawn to,
to put out as much good as possible.
When I hear that story from you just now.
It fucking reinforces what I believe.
- I mean, it's eight minutes later
and then the funny thing was
the tweets rolling in like
"Oh, she's been holding that, like she's."
I'm like, "It's not like that."
- It happens all the time.
I feel horrible 'cause sometimes I see it
but I'm not in that mindset.
Attempt number 494
to get Gary Vee to follow
me or say hi, it's hard.
I'm out here operating and navigating
and trying my best and,
5000 texts a day, 10,000 DMS a day,
thousands of tweets.
You'll never beat the math
but my intent is there and,
you make lemonade out of these lemons.
This whole pandemic has let me connect
with the community at a level,
"Tea With GaryVee" is
a connection point that
is greater than "#AskGaryVee"
is greater than anything I've done,
I think, really, honestly.
It's got a different level of
depth and calmness and speed
that I think is really connected
and helped both me and
everybody who's watching it.
- I'm grateful and I was
thinking last night about how,
I started this non-profit in 2008.
I had been laid off and
when this whole thing hits,
75 days ago.
I remember when I was in New York
and I flew back to California.
You were talking about this
in one of your shows recently.
I didn't get nervous.
- You were there.
- I built this in 2008.
No noise and my brother, an entrepreneur
in his own right in real estate.
He introduced me to you 10 years ago,
and sometimes we'll be hanging out,
I'll be like,
He's like, "Don't be a victim,
"don't be a victim."
I'm like, "Fair."
(Sarah laughs)
- The big thing for everybody
who likes to complain
and dwell and be a victim.
They need to realize that nobody cares
'cause they're worried
about their own problems.
And the only people that
are caring and coddling you
are the people that extremely
love you and enable it.
Or other people that are fucking losing.
Complaining and dwelling is a bad formula,
because it creates too bad relationships.
It creates a relationship
with another losing player
and you're just negative on negative
and you're just hanging out
in your fucking sorrow bubble.
Or it's putting somebody
that loves you so much
in a precarious spot where
they're enabling you,
which eventually leads to
resentment by both parties.
Complaining and dwelling is bad.
It really hurts relationships.
- And people that love you
don't want you to sit in that.
And it's interesting
'cause I don't know if you know what I do.
But I mean, I help teens
become entrepreneurs.
We start them teens, tweening,
and you'll be happy to know that,
our teams run our social media,
because there is no
excuse for not having it
but I personally do not
feel Tik Tok is my jam--
- It is so your jam.
- I'm saying the kids--
- They totally know it.
But in four hours, it could be your jam.
- Yes and they'll teach me.
The fun thing is to be in situations
where I can go to our to our
kids, our teens, our tweens--
- Sarah, let me take this moment
because I'm gonna help a lot of people.
Lemme tell you how to get taught
on Tik Tok, Snapchat, LinkedIn
or the next three things that
happen in the next decade.
You go immediately and you consume content
on the platform for 10 hours.
And then you make 10 pieces of content.
10 hours, 10 pieces of content,
is how you learn every platform.
Go in, download it, read it.
Don't judge them.
Don't say it's stupid.
10 hours of consuming
10 pieces of content,
giving it your best,
and then reassess.
10 hours 10 piece of content
is how every single person can
learn a new social network.
- Well, you should check it out,
because they were shouting
you out yesterday.
- I will check it out.
(Sarah laughs)
- It is such a pleasure.
I'm glad we did this.
- Yeah, thanks and everybody.
I wanna thank you, Gary,
you gave a tip in a video recently
about just reaching out to
people in the DMS on Instagram,
and we're doing a virtual
entrepreneurship summer camp.
And I've reached out to
celebrity entrepreneurs
in every space and we've
had some great yeses.
That would probably not be chillin'
at their house right now.
- Can't get a yes if you don't ask.
- Yeah, so thank you, Gary.
- Take care.
Bye bye.
Dustin, what are the updated numbers?
I wanna start creating the competition.
I wanna get Twitter,
YouTube, Facebook and Twitch,
to start sharing their
URLs to their community
to get to the highest number.
We might have to do a pizza
party for the best guest.
- Pizza party, cool.
- So where are we at?
- YouTube is 3000.
Facebook is 2800, it's close.
Twitch looks like it's 330.
And Twitter looks about 330 or 20ish also.
- Twitter and Twitch have some work to do.
Okay, let's keep it going.
Katie?
- Hello, how are you?
- I'm very well, but your
beautiful setting is inspiring.
- It's the best place to be.
- Good for you.
It's really nice to see you.
- You too, I'm so excited.
I've been playing, what
would Gary say all week.
So all of my questions,
I filtered through what
your response would be.
And I've made a bunch
of changes this week.
But my question is--
- And did you feel any impact
of any of those changes yet?
I mean, it's early.
You have?
Gimme one example.
- So we have a farm market,
and we do home delivery
throughout the capital region,
upstate New York.
And obviously, all food
delivery has skyrocketed
in the last few weeks.
And, we're just growing
so exponentially that
it was scattered,
so we were--
- Of course, when chaos hits,
I mean, it's happening at
WineText right now, Katie.
We hired nine.
The Springfield New Jersey
pool shut down for the summer.
So we hired all nine lifeguards,
and inevitably, some of those kids
are gonna ship the wrong bottle of wine.
When it gets to chaos,
the big key Katie, is
to not beat yourself up.
If somebody gets corn instead of apples,
you could always fix anything
by saying you're sorry and addressing it.
And I think too many people
worry about perfection
or if we deliver the wrong thing,
it gets put on Facebook
and everybody gets mad.
I'm sorry and meaning it
is the greatest antidote
to anxiety around making a
mistake in business and in life.
- Yeah and I try to be super transparent.
We went from just me,
I had knee surgery on February 11th.
And then, three days later,
I was delivering things I
couldn't even put a shoe on yet.
So that was cool.
I was all right, people need food.
So we're gonna get food out.
- I'm impressed.
- I'm like 30x what I
was January, February.
- Have you hired?
- Yes, that's my challenge.
People don't like to show
up to work sometimes.
- A lot of times.
We hired four people last
week, and only one showed up.
And Brandon, my best
friend who has great EQ,
hired as well and really
communicated well.
I think what it comes down
to is not dwelling on that,
recognizing that's going
to be part of the game,
learning and hiring a couple
more people than you need,
just in case they don't
show up in the first day
or quit after day one.
Both happen, no show
and quit after day one.
But the reality is you just keep pushing.
I think Facebook, Craigslist, LinkedIn
are all good places to get individuals.
I think emailing all your customers
and saying, "We're hiring."
Some of those people wanna get
their teenage kids out of the house.
So I think there's some hacks there.
- Yeah and I've done a little
bit of outsourcing too,
so that I don't have to
do everything in house.
- Good job.
- And I simplified things
because I was like,
it ends up I'm pretty much
the primary delivery person.
And we're doing a big range
and I love driving
that's fine, no big deal.
But I love the marketing it,
that's my jam,
that's where I am.
Content and marketing
and business development
and customer relations
and we do handwritten thank
you cards in the orders,
that's my thing.
- What part of New York are you?
I wanna make sure anybody
who's got friends and
relatives in the area--
- We are near Saratoga Springs.
- Saratoga Springs?
- Yes.
- Where do you deliver through?
What areas?
- Albany County, Saratoga County,
Schenectady County, Rensselaer County,
Washington County.
- I love it.
Big shout out to my homie
homie, Joe Menakawa,
Tokyo Joe, as we called him in college
from Schenectady, New York.
I miss you a lot, Joe if you're watching.
- We deliver there Mondays and Thursdays.
- Love it.
So do you have a specific
question maybe I can help with?
- What is the best way to scale,
I don't need to scale huge.
I'm at 15, 20 deliveries.
With our current infrastructure,
I can probably hit like
50 and I don't know--
- So you don't have demand for 50 yet?
- Oh, I do, I just can't, I don't--
- Infrastructure meaning,
the amount of food you make,
it's the delivery part.
- Yes food, cooler space--
- So you mean the delivery infrastructure
is not up to the level
of being able to do 50?
- Mostly the people and the
supply chain and that stuff.
- Is it a hiring?
- I think so.
- Yeah, I think so too.
I think you can't be disappointed
when you hire two people
and spend two weeks on it
and they don't show up.
And so right now, during
this time, especially,
you need to hire anybody
who's willing to say yes,
and you need to take risks.
Ricky might drive away with the food
and eat it in this
house, that might happen.
And then you'll call Susan
in Schenectady
- Or they put it
on the wrong porch.
- Or they put it on the wrong porch.
I think it's okay to go there.
Because here's what
people don't understand.
But they don't eat it.
But they don't put on the wrong porch.
90% of time, it's okay.
And people think the 10% is the 100%.
They fear.
I'd rather say I'm sorry.
And I believe in people.
And I believe in the good.
And I believe it's gonna be okay.
And I'm optimistic.
Optimism is practical, it helps grow.
And so you just can't be scared.
Start with friends and family.
I would go into your
phone from A to Z tonight,
coffee, tea wine, however you roll A to Z
from 6pm to midnight and text every person
and say, "Hey, do you know anybody
"who wants to work?"
Because I need four to five,
I mean, all of them.
- That's where I started
and then friends
didn't show up.
- No, no, all of them.
That happens.
No, no you hit up your closest friends.
You didn't hit up somebody
that you met six years ago
and have their phone in your address book.
That's what I would do.
All right?
- Awesome.
- Good luck.
It's just hiring.
- Thank you so much.
- Don't fear the no show.
Katie, don't fear the wrong delivery.
And I guarantee it will work out.
- Awesome.
- I mean it, I'm positive,
you're welcome.
- I appreciate it.
- People really fear hiring.
I've seen this happen so much.
I've made an ungodly amount of bad hires,
because I don't fear it.
You can always fire that person.
You can always say sorry, you
can always lose one customer.
But if you don't hire 'em,
you're stuck at 15 and not 50.
Simple, let's keep moving.
- Gary Vee, what's going on, man?
- What's good, Andrew?
- How you doing?
This is awesome.
Thank you so much for the opportunity,
I really appreciate it.
So I gotta give you a
little bit of a backstory
just so you can kind of get
caught up on everything.
So five years ago,
I started a social media marketing agency.
Was super tough at first,
made it happen, sold it within two years,
and then transferred over to eCommerce.
Throughout this whole time,
I've always wanted to really
do mentorship type stuff,
speak, because of you actually,
I was always afraid of creating content,
putting myself out there.
For whatever reason, I don't know why
but I listened to you finally a month ago
and honestly I think
I've found my calling,
this is awesome,
I love every second of it,
and it's really cool within--
- Andrew, knowing that you
did a social media shop
and eCommerce and wanna be
an entrepreneurial personal brand,
the only vulnerability the guy like you
has in the cliche scenario
is don't fake the funk.
- Oh, you already answered
my question. (laughs)
- I knew where you were
going based on your setup.
You will win if you don't bullshit
and too many guys like you bullshit,
because they can't wait to
get to the fucking stage part
and the verified part and the fame part.
And that's awesome, there's
nothing wrong with that.
But make sure you really
talk about the truth
of how good or not good your
social media agency was.
How good or not good
you were at eCommerce.
'Cause I see it every day.
People can't wait to get
to the kind of fame part
and so they kinda embellish
or over exaggerate how good
of an entrepreneur they were.
And it fucking always,
always, always bites them
in the ass in the end.
- That makes sense.
Well, lemme ask you this.
So my main concern and you're definitely,
you're on the right track 100%, obviously,
but my main concern is,
when I was younger from 18 to like 23, 24,
I had a heroin addiction.
So I beat it or I'm still
running at it every day,
I've been sober.
- I proud of you.
- Yeah, and I've been
sober ever since and--
- It's powerful.
- The response I'm getting is cool,
but I haven't gone public with it.
And I don't know--
- Well, you just did.
- Yeah, I know.
That's why I said in my question,
I was like this, "If I'm gonna do it,
"I might as well do it like this."
- Andrew, I'm so proud of you, bro.
- Thank you.
I appreciate
- You know how hard that is?
To achieve that--
- Well, that's part of the whole thing.
I remember in the thick of it.
I would be like,
I remember this specific time
when I was sitting on my couch
when it was all happening
and I thought I was never
gonna get out of it.
I thought I was gonna
be like, 75 years old,
and I was gonna be an addict,
or be in that space.
And I feel like I could
help a lot of people.
- You can.
- But I'm also afraid that
it will hurt my credibility.
- No, it will double up your credibility.
- Really?
- Yeah.
It will double up your credibility.
Yeah, I just felt like it's
a negative connotation.
- Look, it's not.
For whoever it's a negative comment.
Whoever thinks it's a negative
is somebody you don't
want in your community.
It's somebody who doesn't
understand it's a disease
and is casting judgment
without fucking any knowledge
of how the actual game is played.
You know what I mean, brother?
- Yeah, that's awesome, thank you.
Honestly, as a matter
of fact, for example,
in that story, in your
truth is exactly the reason
why somebody would be
more connected to you
than connected to me.
Because they're going
through an alcohol addiction
or opioid addiction, you know what I mean?
And I can give them that, but you can.
That's why so many people
aren't getting any traction.
They're just talking vanilla.
They're watching my shit
and regurgitating it.
It's not that true.
- Especially in
eCommerce right now, 100% Absolutely.
- It's your biggest strength, bro.
- It's the biggest thing you got.
Not to mention, I believe,
and this is coming out of
pure love out of my heart
for you specifically.
I also think that if you
make it a pillar you stand on
that it gives you a better
chance to fight it off
for the rest of your life.
Because what people don't know
and what you do know, is a forever game.
And a lot of people win that forever game.
It seems daunting in their 20s,
I met a lot of people who've
had real addiction issues
in their 40s and the
thing they keep telling me
is that in your 20s and 30s,
after you've gotten through it,
and you've been in it
and you're in year one or two and three,
and you're happy
But then there's like,
"Fuck, I gotta fight
this for 60 more years
"and it sometimes feels daunting.
"And kind of getting out of the shadows
"and letting everybody know about it
"has actually given them energy
"to then go that 20 years
"instead of relapsing two years later."
- Yeah, that makes sense.
That makes perfect sense.
That's all, man.
- Brother, It is your strength.
Ready for this bro?
In 2009 people told me and
people told me to my face
and told my agents
that they would not book me
to speak 'cause I cursed.
But I just stuck to my truth.
Do I think the most conservative
company won't hire you
because of that?
Sure, if they've demonized
drugs and sort of,
but do I think three other companies will?
Yes.
Don't worry about it as a stigma,
when it's your strength.
Most people think they're stigma,
most people feel a stigma.
I was raped.
I had opium addiction.
I went to jail.
Theft cyber, security breaches
that put me in, probation,
most people think that there's stigma,
especially when it's not.
As long as you don't murder
someone, rape someone,
as long as it doesn't get to
the top five to seven things
in culture--
- You can't come back from.
- That's why our society
is wildly forgiving.
And it's actually our strength,
but most people think it's their demon.
And it's not, it's their strength.
- Yeah, that makes sense.
And it makes perfect sense--
- Some kid that we hired said to me,
"Gary, I just feel I can say this to you,
I've worked for so long, he was like,
"I went to jail, but you
guys don't know about it."
I was like, "So?"
And then I was like, "For what?"
And he told me, "It was not that bad."
I was like, "Good, okay."
- No, that makes perfect sense.
You just lean into it.
Honestly, I thought of that too.
I just didn't know
if the positives would
outweigh the negatives.
And I remember there were times where
I feel like still to this day,
if I watched a video of
somebody like me now, back then,
I probably would have gotten
sober a couple years earlier
or would have helped me
in one way or another.
- Bro, shadows are heavy.
Secrets, slow you down.
Do you understand that?
Of course, the positives are
gonna outweigh the negatives.
You're not gonna have to think.
What were you doing when
you were thinking about this
and laying there and saying,
"Okay, one day I'm gonna be like Gary Vee,
"and I'm gonna be on stage.
"I'm doing q&a.
"And someone's like
"'Yo, dude, didn't you
have a heroin addiction?
"'I fucking, my brother knows you.'"
What would you do?
What were you gonna do in that moment?
(Andrew laughs)
You can't have that moment.
- No, absolutely.
- You would have sabotaged your own upside
because you would have
feared the exposing moment.
People need to put out
their stigmas to the world
because their secret is
sabotaging their upside
'cause they have to overthink every move
'cause they haven't exposed their stigma.
- Absolutely, yeah, it's
good that I do it now
before it ever gets to
any point like that.
- And even then you should be like, "And?
"Fuck you."
Bro, everybody's got shit.
And you're a hero to break through it.
Not the other way around.
- Shit, man.
- It's a disease bro.
You're not bad.
This isn't 1984 anymore.
Nancy Reagan isn't out here shaming us.
Come on, let's get our shit together, man.
This is a disease.
I'm proud of you.
You fucking accomplished
more in breaking that habit
than 90 fucking percent of
people will do in their life.
I believe that to be true, Andrew.
- Gary, I really appreciate that.
That's super awesome.
And I really do thank you so much.
Thank you for the opportunity, man.
- You got it.
- This was top so I really,
this is awesome, honestly, thank you.
- You're welcome.
Talk to you soon.
Let's get on with it.
Hey, Kendall.
- Hey.
What's up? (giggles)
- What's up with you?
- Good morning.
I'm super excited to be here.
Wait, is that better?
Do I look okay?
- They they both look
great, Kendall, don't worry.
- I got a light and everything.
I'm feeling really professional
right now. (laughs)
- I don't, I look shit.
Everyone's like, "Get a light."
I'm like, "I don't give a fuck."
- And that's what I thought
when I put the light on,
I was like, "Gary Vee
doesn't fucking care."
(laughing)
That's what I thought.
But I'm super excited to be here.
Thank you so much for having me.
They've been trying to
get me on this week.
But what's crazy is this whole week,
I have been waking up
thinking I'm gonna be on.
I get up at 5am 'cause I'm in California,
and it's really changed
because then Tuesday and
Thursday I did the same thing.
And I was like,
"Dude, I'm fucking down
for this, I'm ready."
- Got it.
So you're in Cali?
Obviously I only get to so many
they have to prep for how many I get to.
So you started Monday?
You thought you might be
on Monday if we got to you?
So Monday, and so you had
to get up super early.
And then because you did it all week.
You were waking up what time before?
Like, 9am, 8am that kind of time?
- Yeah, I was staying up till 2:00,
waking up at 9:00.
- And now you're on this,
so are you going to sleep
a little bit earlier?
- Yeah, I'm going to sleep
a little bit earlier--
- And you do you like this vibe better?
- Dude, I love it.
I love it.
I am a professional athlete.
So I've been waking up
super early my entire life.
But now with Coronavirus, how
things have kind of change.
I was just telling my mom earlier
the difference between
going to sleep at 2:00
and waking up at 9:00 or 10:00,
and doing the opposite
where I wake up at 6:00.
The hours are the same,
but what I get done from 10pm to 2am
is so different from 6am to 10am.
So it's been fucking awesome.
So thank you guys just for that.
- You know what's funny is,
one of the biggest reasons I always knew
I could never live in LA
is because the world
navigates around New York.
That's just the truth.
And the thought of waking up at 8am,
but it's 11am in New York,
and the world's been
moving gives me anxiety.
Even when I'm on the
west coast on business,
I wake up at 6:00
and even that's like, it's kind of funny.
- Yeah I know, I feel it.
So I'm super excited to be here.
And I just it took, preface my questions.
Do you know what Jiu-Jitsu is?
Brazilian Jiu-Jitsu?
- I do.
- Okay I thought so--
- Big shout out to Lou levy.
One of my good buddies,
who's super about it.
Go ahead.
- Awesome, cool.
So I'm a black belt.
I'm a seven time world champion.
I've been training since
I was a little kid.
And my main question is 'cause,
I like you and everybody else in the world
have a lot of spinning plates.
So I'm a professional athlete.
My parents own a bunch of
three Jiu-Jitsu academies
and I work out full time
and kind of like you I work with the wine
or the liquor store, I
work at them full time,
my salary stays the same.
But my goal is to grow the
business and reinvest the profits
and it's been growing
crazy the last few years
when I got back from one one
year of attempted college.
So it's been great.
And also I wrestled,
I was an international
wrestler for team USA.
And now, I was really touched by,
was it Andrew that was just on?
I was super touched by him,
'cause I am about to hit
my four year anniversary
of being recovered from bulimia,
which has been a huge interesting
thing in combat sports
with making weight and
that's a whole nother topic.
And then also, I'm
super fucking passionate
about real estate and I have
all this stuff going on.
I have a small following on Instagram,
like around 18,000 or 19000.
Most of it fans of my sport,
Tik Tok I have like 1000, it's super small
and my question to you--
- How many times have
you posted on Tik Tok?
- Good question.
I posted about 20 times
and only in the last week
have I really gone up to
like two, three times a day.
And I'm trying to stay consistent
because the only Tik Tok,
I've ever had go viral was of my dog and
my dog is super funky cute,
but it has nothing to do with me.
- But you know what?
This is something that
people get confused on,
I think you milk, what's the dog's name?
- Bella.
- I think you milk Bella
for a couple months,
and then you slide in the Jiu-Jitsu stuff.
I mean that.
Look, I really believe in that.
I think people are like,
"Oh, but Gary says, 'Don't post like,
"'don't just do it for the likes.'"
On the flip side.
There's a lot of fun stuff
you can do with Bella
and Bella is part of your life.
Bulimia is part of your life.
Jiu-Jitsu is part of your life.
Real estate's part of your life.
I think you can mix it all.
Too many people try to make
their content too narrow.
- So with the content and
I'm kind of you're saying,
I'm doing body positivity stuff,
I'm doing Jiu-Jitsu stuff.
I'm just kind of like,
my boyfriend's super nerdy
and obsessed with Star Wars.
So I'm starting to like put that in there.
Dude, I convinced him to
start going on Tik Tok
and he's the least
social media person ever.
I was like, "There's a place for you.
"Gary Vee said, 'There's a place for you."
So that's another thing, but--
- And by the way,
you two as a combo is a fucking viral hit.
The nerdy Star Wars dude
with the black belt fucking badass chick--
- He's a black belt too.
- Oh fuck, okay, good thing
I didn't call him nerdy
Star Wars dude to his face.
Go ahead.
(Kendall laughing)
So I got the con, I'm
gonna keep doing that.
I put a video of him on my Tik Tok
for the first time yesterday
of us doing a self defense thing,
so I'm pumped about that.
So my question is for
Jiu-Jitsu and wrestling
because our sport is hard as fuck,
but it doesn't make a lot of money.
There's no NBA.
There's no MLB.
There are some sponsors
for me the fights are weird like
in a few weeks I have
a fight where I like,
$2000 to win, $2000 to show
or $2000 to show, $2000 to win.
Then I have something
that I pay to fly there
and there's no payment.
Then I have something that's $500.
So it's super all over the place
and I have some sponsors,
but it's not that much.
- I got it.
- I make way more from
working at the school.
I really wanna see if there's a way,
I fuck with Ashley Graham.
She's amazing.
I wanna see if there's a way
that I can get into that
world bringing more eyes--
- I can save you time.
The answer is yes.
Your charisma and energy is so strong.
You have it.
You just need to go
completely apeshit, obsessive,
which you're capable of,
given what you've achieved in your life
on being a content machine.
Kendall, you're exactly the kind of girl
that needs to be putting
out 25 to 40 pieces
of content a day.
- I started tweeting people.
- Exactly.
You go to Twitter,
and you search every Jiu-Jitsu terminology
and the term and you reply to everybody.
One more time for the kids in the back.
Who don't know how Gary
Vee was created in 2006,
from 2006 to 2011.
For five years, I would
reply to every single person
that tweeted at me
and at first when nobody knew who I was,
I jumped into every word
that was mentioned on Twitter about wine
and joined the conversation.
And I put out a daily wine
video, every single day.
Kendall, you have so much charisma
and great energy and cute and interesting,
and have bullimia
you have everything going for you.
- Okay, so just more content I--
- Like even the way you talk,
I fuck with, I hate, you've got it.
- Okay, yey, I'm excited to do that.
I got Instagram going,
I got Twitter,
I got to Tik Tok.
I have like 50 followers on Twitter.
So I'm writing everyone that
has Jiu-Jitsu in their thing.
'Cause I don't give a fuck and--
- Is this your handle across the board?
- It is, so Kendall Reusing
is obviously my name.
My last name is Reusing
but it looks reusing.
I wanted to make everything,
@Kendallmarie so it's easy.
- No, Kendall, this is back to Andrew.
You're seeing it as,
"Oh no, it's reusing."
Kendall Reusing is the fucking funniest.
That's exactly right.
I'm telling you,
Do you know how bad a
user handle named @GaryVee
with two silent Es are?
"Yo you gotta check out @GaryVee."
They go in, "@GaryVee
where's this fucker?"
In the beginning it was like,
you will make a name.
A name will be made, you understand?
@kendall--
- So Reusing is fine?
- If I were you, I'd be like,
"And this is Kendall Reusing.
"Just kidding."
It's a thing.
- I see, I see, 'cause I was like I--
- Like a secondhand shop,
your biggest sponsor could be goodwill
because people reuse probably like.
(Kendall laughs)
I'm telling you.
- That would be dope.
- It's the same way is like a scar.
Everybody thinks their scarlet
letter is their shortcoming.
It's their strength.
I see, I'm down with it.
I'm down, so everything is every,
well, people will learn to spell it.
It's not like, whatever.
- What do you mean learn to spell it?
Everybody knows how to spell reusing.
What's your last name again, I apologize?
- It's Reusing.
I wouldn't know how to spell Reusing,
I'd be like rosin.
Reuse, no, Reusing is your strength.
- Okay, and last thing,
how much content do you consume
to stay on trend but not to
get sucked into the black hole
'cause Tik Tok is black
hole sometimes for me.
- When you're consuming
it for strategy, unlimited
when you're consuming it for escapism
'cause you're bored or
you're using it for leisure
because you're not happy
with what you're doing, zero.
I consume zero social
media for entertainment.
I use this for entertainment.
And then that's about it.
I use it for strategy and learnings,
the black hole is when you're using it
'cause you're not fired up about
what you're doing in your life.
Or do you just need a break?
I don't wanna demonize
an hour of just going in the feed, do you.
But it's very simple.
It comes completely down to,
are you doing this because
you're actually studying?
I'm in feed studying.
I'm not like, "Oh, that's funny."
I'm like, "Why did she do that?
"What's that Hashtag?
"How many seconds was that?"
Read the comments.
Why do they love Megan Thee Stallion?
You know what?
- Okay, last thing and I'm gonna
get you to the next person,
'cause I'm now that person
that's cutting people off
that are in line.
- I love it.
- Ashley Graham, just that whole world.
There's some other people
that I follow as well.
I know I'm creating content.
How do I burst into that
world coming from an athlete
in a sport that's not mainstream?
- Patience.
One single picture when you're looking,
you're honest, your true self,
but your copy is powerful,
clicks the attention of one person,
and you're on the Today Show.
- I see just keep doing that
and get in front of as many eyes--
- It's fucking reps.
How do I become a black belt?
- Reps.
By coming to class every day
whether you feel like it or not.
- Got it?
- Okay, I got it.
- I think we had somebody
else during this two months,
who was black belt,
I said, "How'd you get--
- The karate guy?
- Kendall, how'd you do it?
That's why I'm a black belt in what I do.
You've gotta put in the fucking work.
It's the work and that's why
I work so much of mindset.
Just like in your world
it's fucking mindset
if you're insecure of how you look
or what people are gonna say,
or that you only have 13 followers
but your buddy has 400 or
whatever the fuck it is
when you said, "I have a
small audience on Instagram."
And threw out some sort of 19,000,
whatever number you threw
out everybody gasped
because they have 310.
- I get into this whole--
- Stop right there.
- Where I don't wanna
give a fuck and then I --
- No, no, no, no, comparing.
If I could fucking take that word
and beat the living
fucking shit out of it.
If I could take comparing
and fucking choke hold the fuck out of it.
Like you know how?
That fucking word.
I fucking hate that word.
People follow me, I don't use hate often.
I hate that word.
You went right to where I
wanted you to right there.
That, that, that, I
fucking hate that word.
- Me too, but it's hard.
- But I'm telling you
have to fucking fight,
everything's hard.
My ability to not compare is
a core foundational strength.
Not only do I not compare,
when I see other businessmen
and women do things
that I haven't accomplished yet.
I applaud if they've
done it the right way,
- I think it's so fucking awesome
to watch people accomplish things.
I just wonder if because I'm not getting
the same response in my content--
- Yo, hold on one second, hold on.
Dustin, throw up,
Whittaker_is_my_dad's comment.
I wanna address this 'cause
it's super fun for me.
It's a super fun comment for me.
I'm sorry, Kendall I just
wanna jump in 'cause--
- No, you're fine.
- 'Cause is one of my
favorite subject matters.
Dustin, I don't know if you
see it, Whittaker_is_my_dad.
Yellow emoji on Twitch.
It's one of my favorite
comments about my energy
that I think a lot about.
Dustin, you sleepin' or you can't find it?
- I'm trying to find it.
- It's in between Barryisenbom
and Ramon_icndavid_abraus
near their Judah_celus.
It was at 9:45pm, Whittaker_is_my_dad.
Kendall, you got this?
Compare, you know.
- So I compare it
when I applaud people for
doing what I haven't done yet.
And I think it's fucking awesome.
And that's amazing.
But I worry that
because I'm not getting the
same response on my content
that means I'm not doing what I needs
to take to get to that
level, if that makes sense.
- That's super smart.
The problem is you
haven't done enough shit.
It's the same reason people are mad
that they don't have an orange belt
and they wanna give up.
You're doing the thing
you understand the best.
- Just do more, more and more and more--
- You don't have context, yet.
You haven't been doing it long enough.
Got it?
- I got you, thank you.
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
- Whittaker_is_my_dad.
What's super interesting is
how many people think that
who confuse optimism and happiness and
just genuine gratitude
with performance enhancement drugs.
If I took an Advil, I go to sleep
because of how little
medicine and drugs my family,
the demonization in
Eastern European family,
especially by mom who was
super affected by Nancy Reagan,
no drugs, no alcohol.
It's so fun to me that is,
I'm always wondering,
who writes that comment?
Do they do Adderall?
Are they so low?
They must be so not optimistic
that they couldn't imagine being happy,
which drives the energy,
makes me really
compassionate and empathetic
Whittaker if you wanna be on the show,
let Dustin know.
I really think about this
shit when people write it.
Because I'm pumped.
I don't know.
Anyway, let's keep it going.
It's so obvious to me that
happiness has the most energy
there is no artificial
drug that beats gratitude.
Just doesn't exist.
All right, let's keep it going.
How's that drink, bro?
- It's good.
Some water, you know what I'm saying?
Hydrated.
- Nav, it's so good to see you, bro.
I'm so proud of you.
I've been so enjoying you navigate.
You know, I've been on you for a minute
just cheering you along
from the sidelines, bro.
You're doing it out here.
- Yeah.
(Nav laughs)
You are man, I'm really proud of you.
- Thank you, man.
I appreciate it, man.
- What's been good?
- Nothing, I just dropped a project.
- I know.
- "Good Intentions" is doing really well.
I put all my energy, my whole
being into this every day.
Thinking about it all day,
thinking about getting better.
I drove myself nuts
just always being like,
"Oh, in this video,
I'm not getting better.
"I'm not getting better.
"I'm not getting better."
And it drove me to just
keep getting better,
I'm just here now.
And I'm just like, "Shit
the whole last year
"and like a quarter has been worth it."
I don't know.
It's kinda crazy.
It's like, running through the
finish line in the marathon.
- Bro, you haven't even started.
You have too much talent in your body.
Bro you haven't even started.
I don't give a fuck how
great this project goes.
Bro you haven't even fucking started.
You're a fucking youngster.
You've got stories and soul.
You really have it bro.
- Yeah, thanks, appreciate it.
- Back to what I was saying
earlier to Kendall, I watch,
you know I watch every,
Eboy puts me under so much stuff,
I watch myself
and I just know where you're at.
- Yo that's for sure.
(Nav laughs)
- Anything on your mind?
Anything I could help you with?
What's your Tik Tok
strategy for this project?
'Cause bro I'm telling you
to be in music and not have
a crazy Tik Tok strategy
for everything you do it's
a huge fucking mistake
and I'm feeling your energy
and I'm really glad you came on the show
because I need a much
bigger fucking strategy bro.
- That was leading into
my question for you,
I have prepared is,
during this time when we
can't do shows and promo
and stuff like that,
like going and doing pop-up or whatever.
What would be your
strategy to promo an album,
during this time?
- Lives, content, lives, content.
But I'm telling you,
even if the whole world was wide open,
the number one piece of
advice I would tell an artist
is to win Tik Tok.
- Tik Tok, okay.
- Tik Tok, bro.
I would DM all 100, 500 top Tik Tok stars
and be like, "Yo, here's my project.
"Tell me if you fuck with it.
"And if you wanna do a little
collab piece of content,
"let's go."
And one of those little
fuckers makes a dance
and it's fucking over.
- Smart, smart.
You know what's sad?
Is that I don't even
have a Tik Tok account.
- Nav, what the fuck bro?
(Nav laughs)
- I know it's bad, I know.
- No, no, it's super bad.
It's like unacceptable.
Bro, it's unacceptable.
You just said to me like,
"I don't breathe oxygen."
(Nav laughs)
- Yeah, I hear you, I hear you.
- You know why I'm so excited right now,
because I've been waiting for my name drop
in one of your fucking songs anyway.
So now I'm thinking like,
Oh, he's gonna say, "Gary
Vee put me on that Tok,
"then I went to the."
I'm already trying to
think about what the fuck
you're gonna say.
- Yeah, yeah, I got you,
I'm gonna give you credit.
- Listen to me, you need to go hard on it.
Yo, hit up the crew let's
get on a Zoom this weekend
or let's get a Zoom Monday
'cause I'm gonna kinda try
to de frag this weekend
but I will help you I
really, really, really think.
You have to understand
the culture and the youngsters love you.
You go in there and really do it right,
you're on the verge bro,
you're on the verge of
some crazy ass shit.
And you know, you know how much time
I spent with Gunna and Kid and DaBaby
I'm telling you listen to me.
You need to download it,
I just said it earlier.
You either download it,
10 hours of consuming it,
just watching fucking
what's going on there
and then 10 pieces of content.
Bro you're this close,
you get one thing lit off on
fucking on Tik Tok right now
during this project
and you go to a completely
different level,
completely different level, bro.
- Shit, I gotta adjust to the times, man.
- You have to.
Remember when you were coming up
and the fucking winners and old cats,
didn't understand SoundCloud,
didn't understand the gram.
You're too young to be old.
- 100%. (laughs)
I like that.
I'm definitely gonna pursue
the Tik Tok thing, man.
- Now.
I'm gonna hit you up Sunday night
and be like, "Yo, what the fuck?"
- I need to see progress.
All right, love you.
Talk to you.
- My boy, I appreciate it, man.
- That's a superstar.
That's a superstar.
You'll see.
Mom, that man right there
might be playing in Zander's Bar Mitzvah.
'Cause he's gonna beg for it.
Hey, Sydney.
- Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
I'm good, thank you.
How are you?
- I'm well.
- I'm coming from Barrie, Ontario, Canada.
First off, I wanna thank you
for having me on the show.
And I'd like to commend Kendall and Andrew
for talking about their struggles
'cause I know how hard that can be,
especially on a platform like this.
It can be really intimidating.
- Very daunting.
- So I have a two part question for you.
And then just a bit of context first.
So I am 22 years old.
I am a month away from graduating
at Western University for kinesiology,
which is it's the movement of the body.
What it undergoes during
exercise and everything.
So when I was first starting high school,
I was really athletic growing up,
I actually developed an eating disorder.
And it was with me for seven years.
- Sorry to hear that.
- It's okay, thank you.
I'm actually two weeks away
from being discharged
from my recovery program.
- Congratulations.
- Thank you so much.
So the issue with this is
when I was in the peak
of my eating disorder,
I jumped at the opportunity
to take kinesiology
because it was so focused towards the body
and I was all wrapped up
in fitness and everything.
And now that my mind is clear,
and I know I should not be
tormenting my body in that way.
I don't think this is
the career for me so--
- Great news, Syd.
You're young as fuck.
- I know.
- This is amazing.
Do you understand how big
of a win this is for you?
Do you know how many people work
for 30 years in something they hate?
And then retire and then
just mope through life?
This is the best.
- I know and it's frustrating
because I loved it--
- It should be.
It's frustrating--
- I loved it at the time and now--
- You're gonna love other things.
What are you gonna just love that?
You're fucking 22, you're
gonna love everything.
- So I was just gonna ask you,
do you have any insight as to
what my next steps could look like?
- You need to you need to
explore every random thought
in your mind around cooking and skiing
and making bread and being a wine expert
and being a video game expert and hair.
Your next step needs to be exploring
just like everyone's next steps should be.
Anything that grabs your curiosity,
you need to watch YouTube videos,
you need to try, you need to order a kit.
You need to find a friend,
you need to talk to people
on Twitter about it.
You need to join a
Facebook group about it.
You need to follow 10 people about it.
You need to go explore.
- I do that too.
It's funny, my parents
make fun of me for it.
But I know
you've said all along.
- It's a strength.
- But you say you're
allowed to change your mind
and my problem is once I find
something I'm in love with it.
And then it just kind of like--
- You're not in love with it.
You're in crush with it.
And then you figure out that
you're not in love with it.
- I watched that.
- But when you find
what you're in love with
that crush will go to love.
You're not in love with it.
You're in crush with it.
You have a crush on it.
"Uh, baking I crush you."
But then three weeks later, you're like,
"Fuck this powders."
You notice, "I don't
like this flower shit."
You know what I mean?
"I don't wanna wait for the
pumpkin pie to come out."
Next, "Uh, skiing, you're cute."
"Oh, I don't like tearing my meniscus."
Next.
You're in crush with it.
- Yeah, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- I knew you're just so smart.
I knew you were gonna bring
me down and help me out.
- Lemme keep building here
and give you a little more.
You're 22.
You don't need to figure out
what you're gonna do with your life ever,
let alone in the next five years.
You need to focus on being happy.
- That's funny, that's
actually a good segway
into my second part of my question.
So it's crazy eating disorders
and I'm sure Kendall probably
knows what I'm talking about
when I say this.
It's like this cloud comes over your brain
and you block out the world,
I had tunnel vision.
All I did in high school was go to school,
then I'd have football practice,
I'd come home, I'd work out.
And then I do homework and go to bed
and I only let myself eat a
certain amount of calories.
And so obviously, that's
gonna have an effect
on your brain.
And I missed out on so much of my life,
my teenage years and I
can't get them back and--
- Me too.
Guess who else missed out on 'em.
(tongue pops)
And let's focus on your next 100 years
and not dwell on your last six.
- Exactly, so with that
when I was stuck in the eating disorder,
obviously like I said,
I didn't really know differently.
I thought that's what I
wanted and everything.
So now that I'm recovering,
and I see that there's
so much outside of this,
I don't want anyone else
to go through what I did,
'cause it's terrible.
- So keep doing what
you're doing right now.
- So how do I actually
change their perspective
when making an impact on
them by telling my story.
- By telling your story?
Lemme ask you a question Syd.
If I told you when you were 99
and you came to heaven,
I was like, "Yo Syd,
remember 'Tea with GaryVee'."
You're like, "Hey Gary,
how have you been?"
I'm like, "Good."
I would say, "Hey, remember
when we talked in 2020
"and you asked that question,
"I said, 'Just make.'
"and you made a bunch of Instagrams
"and Tik Toks and YouTubes
"but then after six months you stopped
"because it wasn't getting traction.
"And you went on and thank God
"it was so great you listened to me
"and you became the
greatest skiing instructor
"of all time.
"Well, I don't know if you know this,
"but this is what's cool about heaven.
"Lemme show you the
woman who you impacted.
"She was one girl in, you
know, in Peru, in Winnipeg,
"in the south side of Chicago
"who did watch you know, your 87 views
"on this one YouTube video in 2021,
"87 people watched it.
"But here's Karen the
one person who watched it
"who you actually, had
she not seen that video.
"Here's what heaven's about,
"this is what what her
life would have been.
"Dead at 31,
"because she destroyed her body.
"But because of your video
that only got 87 views.
"Here was her life,
"grandma, happy life."
Wouldn't it be worth it?
Yeah, and--
- So stick with me.
So then make the video.
You don't need to be 8
million on Instagram.
You don't need to be,
fucking Dr. Phil or Oprah.
Just make the fucking video.
One person, one person, one person.
I've been in that mindset,
the whole time Syd.
Now, it's more than one person,
but I'm still in the one person game.
- And I love that,
I know you aren't a huge
fan of compliments but,
I love how humble you are about it.
And you know, I've been doing that,
I do have a Tik Tok.
I've been posting minimum four times a day
and I'm not doing it for the followers,
but honestly, I could
care less about that.
I don't know how to actually
get it to the people
who I'm trying to--
- They'll find you.
- Connect it to.
Put hashtag, put six hashtags
in your Tik Tok and Instagram
and they'll find you.
If you don't think there's
little girls left and right.
Clicking #eating disorder, #bulimia.
If you don't think that's happening,
you're out of your mind,
put the hashtags in there,
make the content, they'll find you.
Somebody's gonna find
your Tik Tok in 19 years,
and it's gonna help her.
Tell the truth, one person,
tell the truth, one person.
They'll find you.
People are worried about getting bigger.
Focus on putting out the message.
- That's what I want.
I want to even obviously
start with one person
but I'm a dreamer
and I'm in my dream I'd love
to speak in front of a--
- I understand.
- And help them--
But that means you're worried about you.
Worry about them?
- And I want that too.
I have friends that are in
my program and I love them.
- Syd, so many people
roll up to me and like,
"Gary, I wanna be like you,
"I wanna give."
And then you listen to the next
13 things out of their mouth
and they're saying,
"I wanna make $100,000 speaking
"and driving private jets and have fun."
They're not about that giving life,
if you wanna help them, then help them.
Making the videos is helping
them, they'll find you.
Of course you wanna speak
and all this, I get that
and maybe you're good enough,
and maybe you're not.
And that's okay.
And one more time with the heaven story.
Wouldn't it be worth it?
And just like you figured
out something else
wasn't in the cards for you,
you may find out
that you speaking on
public stages about this
is not in the cards for you either.
And that will be amazing.
Or maybe it will be,
but you're never going to figure it out.
If you're not completely
in a selfless mind state
of producing content on all the platforms.
People don't produce on all the platforms
'cause like, "I have
no Twitter followers."
So they don't wanna have
three Twitter followers.
Because they're not
worried about the audience.
They're worried about themselves.
They don't wanna waste their time.
They don't like it how it
feels to have no audience.
- I know I wanna make those videos,
make an impact even on that one person,
but what do I do if that one person
doesn't wanna hear it?
They just don't believe in you.
- You didn't believe
anybody either back then.
- Yeah, I know.
- Sweetheart, most of
the people don't believe
the shit that's coming out of my mouth.
They say they believe it,
but they don't act on it,
which means they don't believe it.
The student always finds the teacher,
there's that saying.
The student finds, some shit like that.
Listen to me.
They will find it.
There are people who've been following,
watch this in the comments.
I don't know what you're watching on,
but I've been watching.
There are people who've
listened to me for four years
and then it was one time,
one video, they were ready.
I broke them down.
They broke themselves down.
If they don't wanna hear it.
There's nothing me and
you are gonna do about it.
More importantly, go back to what I said.
The one person.
If everybody here who wants the
fucking fame and the action,
focused on just one person in their life,
which would be so worth
it by human standards.
It's fucking huge.
It's fucking, what's
the matter with people?
Impacting one person
and making their life better is all time.
Somebody will be ready to hear you.
But if you start putting out
for the purpose of helping one person
versus how do I get more followers,
your content will be different.
And when your content is different.
They'll start working.
- And there's, I'm so sorry.
I know you have people.
It's like, I've been
coming out on Tik Tok.
Just speaking to the camera
talking about my experiences
but I've seen some other people doing
what they eat in a day
and I just don't know if
that's the best idea because--
- Do you want to do that?
- Not really.
- So don't fucking do it.
Just 'cause they have 8000
followers or 8 million followers
'cause they do that, that works for them.
You do you.
Pick a nice little song in the background.
So they find you through a trending song.
Use the hashtags and
fucking stay consistent.
One person.
You don't need to figure out
your life in the next 10 years.
I don't give a fuck what your parents say.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Thank you so much Gary.
You're welcome, bye bye.
- Woof! Good show.
Even late for my next meeting.
Dust, this is one of the best shows, Dust.
They were like bangers.
This was like a great album.
- Yeah, and a lot of good quotes too.
- Yeah, there was a ton of shit,
I'm gonna be so pissed at the team
if we don't have at least
six fuckin' Instagrams
out of this.
There's some bangers here.
This was as good of a show,
it was consistently high
quality, good vibes,
I was in a good zone.
This is one of the better shows.
- It's the Abel Franco.
- Yeah, I mean Abel Franco part,
definitely started me off right.
You know and running up those
fucking hills this morning.
I really think that it was a good one.
I feel this was one of the better shows.
Sign up for WineText.
Check out allinchallenge.com,
pass on the show to others.
Please, if you do anything,
take the URL you just,
watch us on and share in your social.
I love you guys, see ya.
I like that, there's WineText.
- [Tamara] Great show.
- Thanks, Mom, love you.
See you guys.
The people that are gonna win,
over the next five to seven years
are gonna be very comfortable
in controlled fucking chaos.
You don't love the process.
This is dreams we're talking about.
Dreams require sacrifice.
All the more actions
have to then map to it.
Brr, backpack, backpack, backpack.
Nobody gives a shit
about where you grew up.
The whole game is scaling the unscalable,
it's fucking hard work.
It's being respectful.
It's being a good person.
Do that, that's just a good idea.
It's there, the flip game is there.
This house right here is $400.
I stay in my lane, real fucking tight,
but you can't be crippled.
Everybody here is judging themselves.
You're looking at what's
in front of you right now.
You're losing 'cause
you're laying in your bed,
looking at somebody's fucking glamorous,
photoshopped picture of
them doing something cool
and you're envious, and you're
jealous and you're impatient.
And it's crippling your upside.
Lemme just say one more
time if you're confused
what I just said.
I say, put your fucking flag on the ground
of who the fuck you are.
Whoever provides the
most value, always wins.
You're entering, the greatest
five year window of your life.
My only answer to me or anybody
is just like, try shit.
Shut your business down
and go work for an apparel
company for 10 years.
Nobody you've ever met got
there without the hard work.
So you better get your speed up.
You better work harder.
You better work smarter.
If you can't Google stuff.
You're not gonna be able to do anything
that I'm telling you to do.
@Garyveetv, my new account, check me out.
Hope you enjoy it.